so from what you've seen not just your
own videos but other people's what do
you see is one of the secrets to
something going viral or is there
nothing it's just timing it's just the
audience's palette it will do you know
sometimes it is just one thing that's
really shareable like you have to be a
look at it be like is this shareable and
is it not just shareable to your cool
friends is it shareable to someone who
doesn't care about you too or the
community or the comedy scene is just
like I think this is funny or I think
this is interesting and cool there's
also things I think are successful if
people find their kind of the video that
they do whether it's like pranks or it's
you know a guy that I know Jack Douglas
doesn't think called your grammar sucks
and he just takes people's YouTube
comments and comments on the grammar
make sketches around it and that doesn't
it's a little just him talking about it
but people can come every week and no
they're going to get that um I think
that big picture wise that's you know
that's a good that's a good formula for
success is having the thing that you do
that that you're known for that people
can expect every single week and not
just harney it excuse me targeting it to
another youtuber targeting to someone
that works in an office or absolute
changes I mean the world I mean think
about let's wait there was one thing by
the United States the United States you
know the Chi take the cosmopolitan areas
and then from that take the kind of the
niche like you too funny thing that's a
very small part of the United States
there's a whole big party United States
people like uh how does it how does a
movie like that a Kevin James movie no
offense Kevin James about you're
watching this uh how does that how does
that do so why do people keep making it
because the world is not just you know
smug people in LA you know it's not just
people in New York or San Francisco the
United States is a huge place and there
is a market there's a market for
everything but there's a market for
things that you may not think are cool
as a whole there's a whole whole big
world out there that that likes things
that you don't like and if you could tap
into that great i wish i could i'm not
i'm not too cool for anything i want
everyone to love my stuff that's why do
dating and sexy relationship stuff
because everyone's kind of been there
and everyone's interested in that
everyone likes attractive women too
you